this is a hilarious and sad and tragic
and completely predictable story all at
once FoxNews remove Donald Trump from a
picture with Jeffrey Epstein and d'Alene
Maxwell now he Lane Maxwell yeah I just
because I mentioned their names this
video will be demonetised but it's an
important story he Lane Maxwell is the
former girlfriend of the late Jeffrey
Epstein allegedly the recruiter of many
of the women who Epstein is accused of
sexually assaulting and after a long I
guess you could call it an absence at
least from the public eye Maxwell has
been arrested and is scheduled to be in
court this Friday now Donald Trump is
very connected to Jeffrey Epstein we
have countless pictures of them together
there's the video of Trump and Epstein
sort of evaluating young women who were
dancing at a party during the 1990s
Trump and Epstein were accused of rape
by the same then thirteen-year-old girl
that case was eventually dropped take a
look at this video in which Fox News is
doing a story about the arrest of Aggie
Lane Maxwell and they actually Photoshop
out they just cropped Trump out of a
picture with Epstein and it just a
disclaimer this there's this is very
visual so if you're just listening
you're only going to hear what they are
saying but what you will see on screen
is Melania Trump then nouse I believe
before she was married guy Lane Maxwell
Epstein and then there's just somebody
who's been cropped out and that's Donald
Trump take a look at this against
Maxwell which one are you focused on
most and how does the timeline of all
three play out well thank you for having
me and that's a very weak we call it we
call that a compound question there's a
lot going on in that question to kind of
decompress but yeah I would say that all
three of those things are there are
three different areas that we're all
looking at obviously we have the civil
case against Epstein the criminal case
against miss Maxwell that you know if
you look at the original picture which
is widely available of course you see
the four of them it's Trump along with
Melania and Jeffrey Epstein and ghilane
Maxwell so clearly this is an attempt to
rewrite history and remove the
friendship of Trump and Epstein right
well Fox says it was just an innocent
mistake didn't mean to just an accident
check this out they put out a quote
saying on Sunday July 5 a report on g
lane maxwell during fox news channels
america's News headquarters mistakenly
eliminated President Donald Trump from a
photo alongside Melania Epstein and
Maxwell we regret the error it was just
a coincidence right it was they
mistakenly cropped exactly Donald Trump
out of that picture how do you
mistakenly edit someone out of a picture
and not notice that the person you
happen to edit out is the President of
the United States right now and one
thing that's actually a little weird to
me is that Fox used that picture to
begin with why even use that one because
there's plenty of stock photos all over
the place of Epstein with Elaine Maxwell
and someone emailed me an interesting
hypothesis which is you know why they
did this David
they picked a picture that Trump was in
but cropped him out to intimidate Trump
Trump's been going hard at fox news
lately saying that they're falling you
know that you got to watch news max in
oay and fox is bad now Fox is sending
Trump a message we have pictures of you
with Epstein
okay we're cropping you out this time
but if you keep going after us this is
the hypothesis we'll put out the
pictures where you're not cropped out I
don't know it's an interesting idea is
it Fox trying to portray Trump more
positively by cropping him out
is it Trump being protected by Fox News
is it an intimidation signal we don't
really know but what is important to
remember is that these were people who
were around each other frequently
Maxwell now has been moved to the
Metropolitan Detention Center in
Brooklyn New York scheduled to appear in
court on Friday now I just I want to get
this out of the way now if Maxwell is
found dead while in custody and it
appears she committed suicide
there would be no doubt that something
is up right are people on board with me
on this one I'm just getting it out
ahead of time just in case and of course
we hope that that doesn't happen just
want to think ahead as to what
your reaction would be if that were to
take place will have continued coverage
of crop gate on our Instagram page at
David Pakman show and if you want
something lighter
there is a full tour of my backyard
urban garden on my Instagram page right
now at David Pakman if you love feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time check
out one of my all-time favorite apps
called blink it's blink Isleta consume
an entire book on your way home from
work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but you
can try it totally free and get 25% off
a subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video